dear friends I'm classrom and I welcome
you all to Z another meeting of the
world economic forum you may ask what is
the purpose of syllables academic forum
and see I know a meeting here in Davos
it is to bring everybody together also
people from different walks of life
politicians business leaders religious
leaders NGOs what we mean in our world
is dialogue we need to analog because we
have to understand each other as a
battle in a world which is so
diversified where we have so many
different opinions if you want to make
decisions we need to understand each and
all so much better we want to involve
you so we hope that you are engaged as
much as possible and of course we will
try to be completely transparent and to
provide you with a good inside of what's
happening here in two hours so please
follow us please be active please voice
your criticism please voice also your
solutions because the future of the
world is built on a very positive
approach on optimism we can do it